[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
olemps nounours du courage voilà
bouchehr pas trop haut ce que j'ai faim
ma petite échelle
et hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
nounours est un gros nigo qu'en
pensez-vous les enfants et voilà pauvre
nul nous n'allons pas le laisser mourir
de faim plus longtemps pour devenir bon
chemin au nom alors on l'a bien connu
voilà quels gens nous vite
ouf
coucou you personnes
coucou
aux
caisses que joie des biscuits secs lots
allant de l'ours ne cède pas à la
tentation
du doivent écrire tu le sais alors pas
de gâteau pas de gâteau mieux
voyons de retour de trajet
à m 28 ennemis bah non c'est trop pas de
gâteau
ils sont beaux
soient sérieux de north tu veux devenir
beau aimer
[Musique]
ce que j'ai faim
personne ne me voit rien qu'un tout
petit biscuit
l'eau je ne vois pas non
plus
n'ont causé un bon
écho ça fait du bien allons-nous l'ours
fermer les yeux encore une minute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon pauvre thomas il n'avait plus
l'habitude dé douceur
or ce que je me sens bien sauf que je me
sens bien
bien content que tu manges et essai
et bien les enfants je crois que vous
avez raison c'est sûrement mon jean
d'avoir bonne mine
et de toute façon on se sent si bien
quand on a mangé à sa faim je ne ferai
plus jamais de régime idiot
et à présent
[Musique]
oui
moi je mange toujours bien parce que je
veux devenir très grand émoi oui vous
avez raison en dormez-vous vite
là
j'éteins la lumière
bonne ni
même ligne
bonne nuit les enfants vous aussi
j'espère que vous mangez toujours bien
pour devenir grand moi je mangerai
toujours bien patron la nourriture c'est
la santé oh oh tu as raison nous nous
allons en route bonne nuit bonne nuit
ouais
en vain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]